Hallo, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan.
Bist du aufgeregt? Dein Kanzler ist in Washington DC.
Ja, ich hoffe, wir bekommen wieder great television zu sehen.
Ich glaube, sie werden sich Mühe geben.
Vermutlich, ja. Ich könnte es mir auch vorstellen. Wir werden, wenn es besonders interessant wird, das natürlich am Ende des Monats.
Da kommt heute Abend noch das Update zum Besuch.
Ja.
Und wir beginnen jetzt.
Genau. Nein, so schlimm wird es wahrscheinlich nicht werden oder so interessant wird es auch nicht. Mal schauen, weil man weiß ja nie, was der Monat uns noch bringt. Aber wir haben es ja damit einem Präsidenten zu tun, der offenbar noch sehr fit ist. Bei Joe Biden sah das anders aus. Und wir haben ja jetzt eine große Debatte um Joe Biden deshalb, weil es ein Buch gibt von Jake Tapper, der ist von CNN, der ein Buch geschrieben hat über diese Ursünde, wie er es nennt, dass man bei den Demokraten und auch in den Medien solange die Augen verschossen hat, davor wie der Gesundheitszustand von Joe Biden eigentlich ist. Als dieses Buch dann veröffentlicht wurde vor einigen Tagen, hat gleichzeitig die beiden Familie bekannt gegeben, dass Joe Biden an Krebs erkrankt ist. Man hat also damit auch natürlich mit diesem Buch ein bisschen Wind aus den Segeln genommen und gesagt, hier, ich spiele die Musik, das ist unser Thema jetzt hier. Nun gibt es natürlich viel Kritik auch an Jake Tapper. Zum einen, weil er als Journalist die ganze Zeit mitgearbeitet hat an dieser Ursünde und immer so getan hat, als sei mit Joe Biden alles super. Und er gehört mit CNN und mit den anderen daran andockenden Mainstream-Medien natürlich zu denen, die immer gesagt haben, das sind Verschwörungstheorien der Republikaner.
Er hat halt ein besonders schlechtes Gewissen jetzt.
Genau, schreibt also deshalb dieses Buch. Und sogleich wird ihm dann vorgeworfen auch von Jon Stewart zum Beispiel, wenn man jetzt Journalist ist und News hat, dann muss man die News veröffentlichen. Und kann ich sagen, liebe Leute, es gibt wirklich ganz interessante News. Aber da schreibe ich jetzt erstmal ein Buch. Und das erzähle ich euch in einem halben Jahr. Aber ihr könnt schon mal das Buch vorbestellen. Und das ist ja genau das, was jetzt gerade passiert ist. So ist also Jake Tapper nun sicherlich keine Figur, die mir besonders sympathisch ist. Aber doch macht es ja etwas offenbar, was interessant ist. Nämlich, dass wir jetzt, nachdem Biden nicht mehr im Amt ist und so weiter, wir eine Situation haben, in der sich wieder alle einig sind darüber, wie das also mit Biden war. Und man fragt sich ja immer, wie kann es eigentlich sein, dass es dann immer so einen Anstoß braucht, der dann alles, also der das, was schon lange sichtbar war, plötzlich dann auch offensichtlich macht. Denn es ist ja jetzt nicht so, wie Elmar Thewesen oder andere immer suggerierten. Nee, nee, also bis vor fünf Monaten war Biden wirklich topfit. Aber dann kam dieses Duell und da hat man gemerkt, jetzt ist es vorbei mit ihm. Da hatte er nicht nur einen schlechten Tag, sondern ging es dann wirklich bergab. Und da war auch schon die Wochen davor das Merkwürdig, sondern dass Joe Biden jetzt nicht der Fitteste ist kognitiv mehr, das war ja schon häufig zu sehen. Aber irgendwie braucht es dann immer was. Vielleicht hören wir mal da rein in so ein Interview mit Jake Tapper, wie er das jetzt schildert. Und zwar geht es um eine Begegnung zwischen Joe Biden und George Clooney. Und wir alle wissen, wie George Clooney aussieht, nämlich wie George Clooney.
George Clooney hatte Joe Biden kennengelernt. Er hat ihn nach 9-11 getroffen und er hat ihn seit Biden als Vizepräsidenten kennengelernt. Und so hatten sie eine Begegnung. Und dann, als Biden für einen Präsidenten rannte, hat Clooney ihm Geld geholfen. Sie hatten eine Begegnung. Sie wussten sich. Bei dem Fundraiser geht Joe Biden rein, und George Clooney kann nicht glauben, wie alt er ist und wie alt er aussieht. Er hat ihn im Dezember 2022 gesehen, und wie wir in dem Buch schreiben, gibt es einen sehr großen Verlust im Jahr 2023. So Biden geht rein, und er hat einen Aiden, und er geht herum und sagt, hey, wie geht's? Danke für das Wissen. Hey, wie geht's? Danke für das Wissen. Und ein Aiden bringt ihn zu Clooney und sagt, du weißt George, und Biden sagt, hey, hey. Und es fängt an, Clooney und ein anderer Wissens, Joe Biden, er erkennt George Clooney nicht. Und das ist nicht George Clooney, mit schwarzen Haaren, die für den Spiel auf Broadway gespielt haben. Das ist nicht George Clooney mit einem Haar. Das ist George Clooney, wie er in den letzten 30 Jahren war. Einer der weltweit bekanntsten Gesichter und jemanden, den er seit mehr als ein Jahr kennt. Und dann sagt die Aide, George Clooney. Und Biden sagt, oh ja, oh ja. Und das schreckt Clooney zu seinem Korps. Aber außerdem, Bidens Performance im Hintergrund.
War, dass Joe Biden wie eingefroren dasteht und Barack Obama neben ihm steht, dann ihn so beim Arm nimmt und mitnimmt von der Bühne. Und das war dann ein besonders drastischer Ausfall. Und dadurch, dass George Clooney anwesend war und George Clooney sich ja dann später dazu äußerte, dazu kommen wir noch, ist das dann so publik geworden. Und war das dann sicherlich ein Schritt, der dazu geführt hat, dass Joe Biden nicht noch einmal antritt. Aber man fragt sich natürlich schon, diese Journalisten haben ja Joe Biden so häufig erlebt. Die Leute in seinem Umfeld haben ihn erlebt. Was passiert da eigentlich mit der Macht, wenn das noch weiter gedeckt wird? Und was bedeutet das eigentlich, wenn wir die ganze Zeit von Vertrauensverlusten und so weiter reden, wenn sowas passiert? Also ich meine, es ist doch schon eine sehr eigenartige Zeit, dass wir diese ganzen wunderbaren Podiumsdiskussionen haben. Wie gewinnen wir die Leute für die Demokratie zurück? Wie schaffen wir Vertrauen und all das? Und dass aber in diesen Diskussionen ja fast nie vorkommt, zum Beispiel sowas wie Joe Biden. Also was ist denn da eigentlich passiert für eine große Lüge? Anders kann man es ja nicht bezeichnen. Wir könnten jetzt durch die ganzen Sachen durchgehen. Der Impfstoff schützt nicht nur mich, sondern auch andere. Der Letzteres stimmte nicht und das hätte man auch früher sagen können. Man hat Ursula von der Leyen, die immer irgendwelche SMS dummerweise verschusselt. Wir haben einen Cum-Ex-Kanzler gehabt. Also ich meine, das sind ja schon alles Dinge. Die Russen haben Nord Stream 2 Pipeline gesprengt. Nee, waren sie dann doch nicht. Auf keinen Fall kann das Virus aus dem Labor sein. Na ja, vielleicht, aber jetzt doch. Es gibt zumindest Erkenntnisse. Also da kann man ja nicht sagen, dass die Öffentlichkeit einfach misstraut, sondern man muss ja eher sagen, man misstraut zurecht.
Also es gibt einen längerfristigen Diskurs, ich sag mal so vor zehn Jahren ungefähr, ob man Nachrichten so aufbereiten müsste wie Wikipedia. Also irgendetwas passiert, gerade in Todesfällen. Und dann steht ja relativ zügig das Todesdatum in der Wikipedia, also sobald es publik ist. Und bei der Frage, wer war diese Person, bleibt man dann einfach bei Wikipedia und liest diesen Artikel. Und das ist mir vorhin wieder aufgefallen, denn als ich auf dich gewartet habe, habe ich so geguckt, was ist es schreibt Spiegel gerade zu aktuellen Geschehen. Und jetzt mal ein Beispiel aus dem Spiegel. Passend, ich lass mal das Thema und die Überschrift weg, der Text. Passend zum Antrittsbesuch von Bundeskanzler Friedrich Merz in Washington zeichnet sich eine wichtige diplomatische Personalie ab. Nach Spiegelinformation soll der Diplomat Jens Hannefeld, deutscher Botschafter in den USA, werden. Hannefeld ist derzeit als Botschafter in Äthiopien eingesetzt. Über die Frage, wen Bundeskanzler Merz und sein Außenminister Johannes Wadepuhl nach Washington entsanden, war zuletzt viel spekuliert worden. Der bisherige Botschafter, bla bla bla bla, geht jetzt in Ruhe stand. So, ich wollte diesen Text nicht lesen, um zu erfahren, dass Wadepuhl und Merz eine Diskussion über irgendwas führen. Ich weiß auch, dass Merz in Washington ist. Das sind alles Infos, die brauche ich einfach gar nicht. Ich wollte einfach nur wissen, wenn eine Überschrift lautet, Jens Hannefeld sei deutscher Botschafter in Washington werden, wer ist dieser Mann? Ja. Also ist es mittlerweile so weit, dass ich auf einem Spiegeltext bin und dann lieber zu GPT rüber gehe und einfach frage, wer ist denn dieser Typ? Und dann sagt mir GPT einfach, Jens Hannefeld ist ein deutscher Diplomat, geboren 1964 in Köln, seit September 2024 Botschafter in Äthiopien, so gleichständiger Beobachter über die Afrikanische Union, für die Afrikanische Union. Nächster Satz, Hannefeld studierte neuere Geschichte und Anglistik und so weiter und so fort. Das wird einfach informiert. Also dieser Journalismus ist in allen Ebenen einfach intellektuell bankrott. Und es ist bei diesem Buch von Jake Tapper, John Stewart hat es ja ganz wunderbar. Hast du Clips von John Stewart? Nein. Also John Stewart hat ja wirklich, da kommt ja dieser ganze Doppel- oder Dreiklang, Leute machen News. Und dann denken sie, nee, die sind so gut. Ich mache ein Buch draus, aber ein Buch dauert Zeit. Und eigentlich unterstellt man ja Journalisten schon immer, sie verwechseln sich so als Teil des politischen Systems. Sie wollen Einfluss nehmen. Also kommen sie schnell mit News, um noch Einfluss auf die Wahlen zu nehmen. Nur die Wahlen sind ja gelaufen. Und dann kommt ein Jahr später ein Buch, das uns etwas exklusiv verraten möchte. Und so wurde es ja ganz aggressiv bei CNN promoted, mit einer Nachricht, die schon vor einem Jahr eigentlich gar keine Nachricht hätte mehr sein dürfen, weil die journalistische Pflicht ist, uns darüber zu informieren, dass das der Sachstand ist und dass das hier keine Neuigkeit ist. Also dieses Buch, ich werde nachher noch was Konstruktives dazu sagen, aber dieses Buch von der Anlage, von der Art, wie es in die Welt kam und wie es promoted würde, ist wirklich eine Bankrotterklärung dieser Art Journalismus. Und bei allen, du hast es angesprochen, Podiumsdiskussionen und hier Ertüchtigung der Menschen, Bewusstwerdung, Sensibilisierung für Demokratie. Die Menschen haben das nicht nötig. Die Journalisten haben das nötig. Es ist wirklich ganz schlimm. Und diese Begleitung von Trump jetzt in Amerika, dass wir morgens Podcasts haben, von denen wir genau wissen, wenn wir heute fertig sind mit dem Podcast, und ich fange 18 Uhr oder so an, diese zu hören, es sind die alle Nonsens. Ja. Weil bis dann ist das gelaufen. Es wird ganz anders gewesen sein, als alle dachten vorher. Alle Szenarien sind total Nonsens. Und es ist stundenlange Podcast-Produktion, die für die Tonne ist.
Man könnte es ja eigentlich auch sehr gut parodieren. Also es geht ja bei solchen Podcasts. Es geht ja dann bei solchen Treffen. Dafür darf ja eh dann der Journalist nicht mehr irgendwelche Namen konkret nennen, sondern wir haben über Kreise gehört. Man weiß auch gar nicht mehr, wie entfernt sind eigentlich die Kreise derjenigen, die jetzt wirklich in Washington mit Friedrich Merz sind. Und dann heißt es dann so, ja, es gab vorher auch Absprachen, man will ihn nicht provozieren, man will nicht dies machen, man will nicht das machen. Also im Prinzip könnten wir jetzt Karl zum Podcast aufnehmen und einfach sagen, ja, Kreise haben uns gesagt, es gibt die Strategie, versuchen mit ihm einen guten Deal auszuhandeln. Aber manche, es ist noch so und so und so, wir wissen es noch nicht genau, aber wir können schon mal Mutmaßen. Völliger Nonsens.
Deutsche Journalisten, die jetzt dabei sind, sitzen bei einem Fußballspiel, im allerletzten Rang, in der allerletzten Ecke, hinten irgendwo haben keinen Fernglas, haben keine Wiederholung, haben keine Zeitlupe, gar nichts. Die können uns nichts erzählen darüber. Die können nur sagen, wir sind dabei gewesen. Und dann gibt es Fotos von, guck mal, wie wir alle flach auf dem Boden liegen, weil gerade Raketenangriff war. Wir sind ja hier in der Gefahrenzone und so was. Und darüber wird so eine Tension aufgebaut. Und der Rest ist... also ich bin, ich sehe ja schon wieder so ein dickes Buch, ich weiß gar nicht, was das ist, aber...
Das ist eine Biografie über Thomas Mann.
Ah ja, also diese Aufarbeitung über Rom, die einfach mit 2.000, 3.000 Jahren Abstand geschrieben werden, treffen den Ton. Und da steht alles Aktuelle drin, was wir wissen müssen. Wir müssen nicht über März informiert werden, wir kennen März, und zwar aus Jahrhunderten, Jahrtausenden Menschheitsgeschichte. Wir wollen jetzt wissen, was hier passiert.
Aber lass uns doch mal einen Moment über diesen Vertrauensverlust, wie das immer so gern genannt wird, reden. Findest du es nicht erstaunlich, dass der Journalismus, also ich habe ja irgendwann schon mal gesagt, beim Journalismus ist es so, wie bei täglich größtes Murmeltier, immer Tag eins, es gibt es keinen gestern. Und das ist ja wieder hier zu beobachten, dass plötzlich alle sich einig sind. Ja, stimmt, das war aber wirklich unglaublich, dass man nicht die Öffentlichkeit aufgeklärt hat darüber, wie es Joe Biden geht. Und deswegen sitzt man dann ein Jahr später da und liest noch mal ein Buch dazu, zu etwas, was man schon ein paar Jahre vorher hätte aufschreiben müssen als Journalist. Und jetzt sind wir wieder in einer Situation, wo neue Dinge kommen, bezüglich Krieg, Verhandlungen, was auch immer, Nau-Ost. Und dann sagt man immer später, ja genau, das war ja klar. Also ich könnte Artikel hier vorzeigen, ich glaube zum Beispiel aus der Augsburger Allgemeinen, nach dem 7. Oktober, wo man sagte, jetzt man nicht zu sehr die Bilder von den Kindern aus Gaza in die Köpfe bringen lassen. Aussagen von Politikern, Michael Roth und dergleichen, jetzt nicht sich hier durch Mitleid irgendwie in eine falsche Richtung bewegen lassen.
Nicht auf die Schleimspur der Hamas-Propagandisten.
Also gar nicht darauf reinfallen. Plötzlich schreiben dann zum Teil dieselben Journalisten, gut Michael Roth ist unverbesserlich, aber die Journalisten schreiben dann, so kann es nicht weitergehen. Man darf nicht wegschauen. Und ich denke, ja aber ihr habt doch noch vor einigen Monaten geschrieben, wir sollen jetzt erstmal wegschauen. Und dass das dann sich aber immer direkt so anpasst wieder. Und plötzlich so ein neuer Mainstream entstanden ist. Also heute wäre ich ja jetzt total anti Mainstream, wenn ich sagen würde, also Joe Biden ist topfit, der sollte nochmal versuchen anzutreten beim nächsten Mal. Dann würde man sagen, jetzt bin ich verrückt geworden. Es ist wirklich erstaunlich, wie so eine Hegemonie sich so schnell immer bilden kann. Und es funktioniert nur, wenn man wirklich sagt, was schert mich mein Geschwätz von gestern. Heute ist wieder Tag eins, heute machen wir wieder weiter. Und das ist ja auch der Versuch von Jake Tapper dann. Insofern ist es ja erstaunlich, dass ein George Clooney, der das nicht hätte machen müssen, sich dann damals publizistisch geäußert hat und gesagt, das ist der falsche Mann, der beiden darf nicht noch mal antreten. Ich habe den erlebt. Und der wird jetzt auch von Jake Tapper noch mal interviewt, also aktuell.
Du bist selbst etwas gemacht, was viele Leute als brav nennen würden, wenn du dein Op-Ed geschrieben hattest.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es brav war. Es war eine zivilische Pflicht, weil ich fand, dass die Leute an meinem Seite der Straße, ich bin ein Demokrat, ich bin ein Demokrat in Kentucky, also, ich verstehe es.
Wenn ich Leute an meinem Seite der Straße sah, die nicht die Wahrheit sagen, Ich dachte, das war der Zeitpunkt.
Einige Leute, klar. Das ist okay.
Du weißt, hör mal, die Idee der Freiheit der Sprache, die spezielle Idee ist, du kannst keine Freiheit der Sprache beherrschen und sagen, aber sag nicht schlechte Dinge über mich.
Das ist das Deal.
Du musst einen Stand nehmen, wenn du in den Weg glaubst, einen Stand nehmen, einen Stand für ihn, und dann verhandeln mit den Konsequenzen.
Die dunklen Haaren. Man wünscht es ja sofort.
Oder es ist musical, also ich glaube es ist die Theater oder. Man hat ja auch schon die Es ist A Good Night, ein Good Luck. Also der Film als Theaterstück, so scheint mir.
Theater, egal ob gesungen wird oder nicht. Man sieht ihn so und denkt sich, warum nicht? Er macht das jetzt, also so wie man ihn da sieht, will man ihn als Präsidenten sehen.
Ach so.
Und da ein Präsident ja einfach nur Aushängeschild eines politischen Apparats ist, der sich dahinter versteckt. Und wir gesehen haben, wie gut man sich in diesem politischen Apparat verstecken kann. Könnte man ja dieses Prinzip umdrehen und sagen, anstatt dass der Apparat den Präsidenten versteckt, versteckt der Präsident jetzt mal den Apparat. Denn das, was wir bei Joe Biden gesehen haben, ist absurd. Das, was wir bei, also jetzt gerade sehen, mit dieser Fernsehshow, dass einfach was auch immer, gar nichts mehr versteckt wird, sondern nur gefragt wird, wo kommt das blaue Auge her? Ich habe meinem kleinen Sohn gesagt, er soll mich schlagen, dabei war das wahrscheinlich der Finanzminister, mit dem er sich gebrügelt hat. Ja, solche Sachen. Dann doch lieber so. Also man kriegt sofort so eine Verlockung, wenn man ihn hier so sieht.
Du gehst ja auch nicht davon aus, dass die Demokraten jetzt daraus lernen werden aus dem Buch, in dem sie jetzt sagen werden, passt auf, ab sofort machen wir das wirklich demokratisch. Wir wählen wirklich, wer der nächste Präsidentschaftskandidat werden soll, sondern wir werden immer weitermachen mit diesen Machenschaften, damit ja nicht mal jemand wie ein Bernie Sanders oder so da rauskommt. Am Ende bei einer demokratischen Wahl machen wir lieber unsere Ränkespiele weiter im Hintergrund irgendetwas und dann kann man nur hoffen, dass es demnächst nicht wieder jemand ist, der nicht mehr so ganz geistig da ist.
Die Demokraten waren damals überrascht davon, dass Obama in Iowa diese ersten wirklich aufs Publikum treffenden Wahlen gewonnen hat und sie konnten nichts gegen ihn tun. Dann haben sie später gemerkt, nein, wenn uns das nicht noch mal passieren darf, dass wir überrannt werden, überrascht werden als Partei, müssen wir Vorkehrungen treffen. Also haben sie diese Superdelegates und so weiter, die Clinton hofiert haben und Bernie Sanders verhindert haben. Bei Joe Biden ähnliche Prinzipien. Man hat gesagt, naja, die ersten Vorwarnungen sind gar nicht so wichtig. Es ist South Carolina. So, dass da aber so eine Black Community wirklich aufgestachelt wurde zu sagen, wir gehen jetzt auf Nummer sicher. Wir wählen den Alten, der schon immer jahrzehntelang für uns was getan hat, während die anderen Jungen auf der Bühne da gar nicht konkurrieren konnten. Und eigentlich für alle Welt klar war, das ist ein Sonderfall. South Carolina ist nicht Amerika, sondern da greifen wie in jedem Staat eigene Prinzipien und die wurden gezielt angesteuert, gehypt, ausgebeutet. Und plötzlich war er der Kandidat. Das sind ja auch wieder solche Prinzipien. Die Republikaner waren ja, ich hab das immer noch im Ohr, wie Orinus Priebus da sitzt und sagt, während sich Obama auf der Bühne macht, macht sich Obama lustig über die Republikaner, weil nachdem 17 Republikaner auf der Bühne stehen und es sind nur noch elf und Trump steht immer als Leader der Vorwahlen schon in der Mitte und so, es läuft eigentlich darauf hinten aus. Alle machen sich drüber lustig. Und Reince Priebus damals, die haben ja nicht richtig einen Parteichef, aber so ein Organisations-CEO irgendwie für die Republikanische Partei sitzt so zurückgelehnt mit Füßen auf den Tisch da und sagt, ja, wir lassen einfach die Leute wählen und danach arbeiten wir mit dem, was ist. So und er hat natürlich schon sein Finch in den Wind gestellt, so dass er schon von Trump vor den finalen Entscheidungen namentlich immer erwähnt wurde und dann auch sein erster Stabschef wurde, der zumindest ein halbes Jahr durchgehalten hat. Die haben einfach den Prozess laufen lassen und wir wissen ja, zu was es geführt hat. Die GUP gibt es nicht mehr, es ist auch nicht Tea Party, sie ist mager. Es ist ein völlig eigenes Ding. Ja, da voran die Demokraten Angst. Genau, aber das Einzige, was die Demokraten überhaupt als Partei retten kann, ist, dass sie sich öffnen für einen Prozess, der sie komplett umkrempeln könnte. AOC könnte da mit so einem Populismus reinlaufen und sagen, jetzt ist die Jugend dran, jetzt sind die Frauen dran, jetzt sind wieder die Urbanzentren dran. Und das würde ja, also wenn man es durchrechnet, mathematisch reichen. Man muss halt nur die ganze Kampagne geschlossen darum bauen. Man darf dann nicht wieder so, ah nee und hier und überhaupt, die müssen wir erstmal ein bisschen einhegen. Und später muss der Apparat aber auch noch zur Geltung kommen. Nee, wenn sie das, ja, deswegen ist, ich glaube der Wettstreit, der große Wettstreit zwischen Republikanern und Demokraten, der ist vorbei. Also da suchen nur noch Journalisten nach, aber das ist so vorbei. Es ist jetzt mager gegen und dann ist die Frage, großes Fragezeichen, was kommt bei rum? Wie gesagt, ich könnte mir George Clooney da vorstellen.
Tja, hoffentlich ist er klug genug, das nicht zu tun.
Aber das Präsidentenamt wurde jetzt so definiert, dass es folgerichtig ist, dort ein Schauspieler, der gemoffen wird.
Ja, da haben wir schon mal hier meinen Vorschlag für die Linkspartei damals.
Genau, den da hinzusetzen.
Als die große auf der Kandidatensuche war, habe ich hier gesessen und gesagt, am besten wäre, man würde einen guten Theater-Schauspieler nehmen, den bezahlen und sagen, du bist jetzt der Vorsitzende der Linkspartei. Also das war, bevor diese neue Riege jetzt aufgetaucht ist und sagen, hier sind 7000 Euro im Monat, du spielst jetzt den Vorsitzenden. Hier sind die Talking Points, aber verkörpere es vor allem. Verkörpere den Politiker.
Zeig uns, was wir sehen wollen, mach die Ansprachen richtig. Und dafür braucht man, das ist eine eigene professionelle Erfordernis und Klasse. Und gerade in Amerika gibt es ja Menschen, die das können. Man muss ja nicht immer hoffen, dass die dann auch noch Politiker sind. Das wäre so bei Gavin Newsom oder so. Der funktioniert vor der Kamera, aber eben auch als Politiker. Aber ich finde, man könnte dieses präsidiale Amt, das ein politisches ist, von Politik befreien. Wir haben den englischen König davon befreit, wir haben den heiligen Stuhl davon befreit. Wir können auch den amerikanischen Präsidenten davon befreien.
Wir sehen zumindest, es macht keinen großen Unterschied, wenn der Präsident gar nicht mehr richtig einsatzfähig ist, sondern nur noch ein paar Stunden am Tag überhaupt ansprechbar ist.
Wir haben doch gesehen, wie weit ein Apparat es treiben kann und sogar das Land so regieren, dass man heute sagt, Joe Biden halbtot, Joe Biden Regierung, besser ever, hätte Amerika nicht besser passieren können. Also die Differenz ist doch voll etabliert.
Ja, es ist ja auch interessant, dass wenn dieses desaströse Duell nicht gekommen wäre und Biden hätte sich noch ein bisschen zusammengerissen oder man hätte die Auftritte noch mehr reduziert, hätte ihn noch mehr versteckt vor der Öffentlichkeit, was man ja wohl auch getan hat, dann hätte es ja durchaus sein können, dass er noch mal Präsident geworden wäre.
Also es ist ja nicht ausgeschlagen.
Also er wäre nicht unerfolgreicher gewesen als Kamala Harris, glaube ich. So, und das sagt doch vieles aus. Wir hätten ihn vermutlich danach nur noch zur Inauguration gesehen und das wäre es dann, noch mal hin und wieder eine Großbotschaft zu Weihnachten und andere hätten regiert.
Ja, und wenn man das Amt auf der Schauseite mit nichts ausfüllen kann, stellt mir vor, was es ist, wenn man das mit was ausfüllt.
Jaja, gut, wir wollen ja jetzt nicht die Demokraten beraten, sondern noch einmal über diese Frage des Vertrauens sprechen, beziehungsweise wie geht man eigentlich mit Politikern um. Im Grunde, wir haben es ja in Deutschland gut. Hier wird ja der Parteivorsitzende der SPD ganz demokratisch bestimmt. Er ist der Talentierteste, der Eloquenteste. Er ist der, der erfolgreichen Wahlkampf für Olaf Scholz gemacht hat, zumindest mal irgendwann. Und es ist doch klar, dass das der große Vorsitzende werden muss.
Es ist alles folgerichtig, super leicht erklärbar. Da ist gar kein Mysterium noch, das offen ist oder so.
Also Lars Klingweil, so ein Star. Da ist doch klar, dass da niemand dran vorbeikommt. Das ist wirklich, ja. Wir hören noch einmal Jake Tapper.
Lass mich noch eine Parade machen. Sie liegt mir auf dem Herzen. Aber wir haben jetzt diesen Kontrast gerade aufgemacht. Amerika, Deutschland. Und wir haben eigentlich jetzt gerade gesagt, alles, was ich gerade über Joe Biden, Hillary Clinton, Obama gesagt habe, ein Apparat, der sich und so weiter. Das gilt ja eben auch für die SPD. Nur, dass wir ein System haben, das auf dem Blatt Papier anders aufgestellt ist, sodass unsere Verwaltung und unsere Abläufe uns davor schützen, dass diese Egozentrik, die da drinsteckt bei Merz und Klingball, gebremst wird. Aber eigentlich, wenn wir ganz ehrlich sind und so meditativ und nicht über Spiegel Online uns mit den Sachen befassen, ist doch völlig klar, Friedrich Merz ist ein gebändigter Donald Trump. Der ist einfach nur Contained. Aber in der Anlage würde der als amerikanische Präsident doch genauso funktionieren, wenn er mit Talenten, die er selber nicht unter Kontrolle hat, sondern die einfach Gott gegeben sind oder nicht, auf der Bühne so funktionieren würde. In einem amerikanischen System würde Merz doch genauso funktionieren.
Wir sehen das doch jetzt sehr gut an den Äußerungen, nicht nur von Friedrich Merz, sondern von Dobrindt und anderen, in Bezug auf die Zurückweisung von Asylsuchenden an der Grenze. Die Gerichte sagen nein, die CDU, CSU sagt, wo kommen wir denn jetzt dahin?
Genau.
Wir machen doch jetzt hier unsere Sache. Das ist genau das. Und ja, das ist besser eingehegt noch. Noch, muss man dazu sagen. Aber ja, die Anlage ist vollkommen da. Deshalb, glaube ich, ist es jetzt auch nochmal wichtig, wenigstens eine Lehre aus diesem Jake Tapper-Buch zu ziehen. Und Jake Tapper zieht sie selbst. Und wir müssen das klar machen. Jake Tapper ist für CNN, so wie früher Klaus Kleber für ZDF, die Galleonsfigur schlechthin. Und die sagt jetzt Folgendes.
Und ich denke, dass wir skeptisch sein müssen, dass alles, was wir von den Menschen in der Macht sagen, und das sollte natürlich das Mantre sein, als Journalist zu beginnen. Wenn deine Mutter dir sagt, dass sie dich liebt, bekomm eine zweite Nutzung. Aber wir müssen das nur erinnern. Politiker leiden, White House leiden, der Macht ist ein Afrodisiak. Und wir müssen das alle erinnern und nicht alles, was wir von ihnen sagen, als Fakten zu nehmen.
Ja, das ist das Interessante. Er braucht dafür jetzt drei Jahrzehnte, um das formulieren zu können. Er hätte man ein bisschen früher mit einsteigen können. Aber ja, das ist der Punkt. Und nicht einfach, weil die nur Lügner sind, sondern weil die Macht zum eines da zuführt. Und aber auch, und da sind wir wieder bei Rutger Breichmann, weil natürlich dort Persönlichkeiten sind, die bereit sind, genau nicht irgendetwas Persönliches hinanzustellen, um das Volk, den Staat oder was weiß ich, zu schützen. Sondern sie sind dann sogar bereit zu sagen, ich werde halt nur noch hinten und vorne mit Klammern zusammengehalten, ich kann aber trotzdem nochmal Präsident werden. Wir hatten das ja auch bei den Richtern. Keiner dieser Richter ist zurückgetreten und gesagt, ich mache jetzt, während Biden regiert oder Obama regiert den Weg frei, für eine weitere progressive Richterin oder so, sondern man bleibt bis zum allerletzten Tag im Amt, weiß, dann wird man wahrscheinlich unter der Amtszeit von Donald Trump sterben und dann hat Donald Trump die Möglichkeit, seine Richter zu besetzen. Und diese Leute kleben an der Macht, egal was passiert und sind völlig uneinsichtig.
Genau. Und um das zu plausibilisieren, werde ich jetzt mal eine Zahlen, Ziffern-Poarte nennen, aus einer Lektüre, die ich heute mitbringe. Apple in China, ein Buch von Dings McGee. Also man kann sie nicht glauben. Ich sage euch jetzt, ihr werdet sie nicht glauben, aber sie stimmt. Ich habe es jetzt wirklich tausendmal nachgerechnet. Es ist unglaublich. Denn ja, wir können immer sagen, Politiker lügen oder die sind rot-glau-brechmann-mäßig durchgeknallt, wie auch immer. Also sozusagen in diesem Kontrast aus System und Person, immer auf die Person gehen und sagen, da liegt unser Interesse, da liegt unsere Sehgewohnheit. Wir gehen ins Theater, wir gehen in die Oper, wir gucken Fernsehen, wir sehen Personen und wir blenden immer das System aus. Und ich habe jetzt schon häufiger so gesagt, grundsätzlich wird immer übersehen, wie groß so Systeme sind. Würde Friedrich Merz in einem 8-Stunden-Arbeitstag sagen, ich möchte jeden Deutschen für eine Minute sprechen, kennenlernen, kurz fragen, wie es ihm geht. Wie lange würde er brauchen? 700 Jahre. Das ist noch nicht die Pointe, sondern Deutschland ist viel größer, als man glaubt. Man bräuchte 700 Jahre, um jeden Deutschen kennenzulernen, was schon mal biologisch gar nicht geht. Da liegen Kräfte drin. Masse ist Macht. So, mal ganz einfach. Und jetzt zu dieser Zahl. Apple ist ein Unternehmen, das ein Wechselbad der Gefühle für seine Aktionäre durchgemacht hat. Steve Jobs gründet es mit Steve Wozniak. Die machen diesen Apple II, löten so die ersten Chips zusammen, verkaufen das, Verkaufserfolge. Sie brauchen so Leute, die das herstellen, wie auch immer. Dann wird Steve Jobs da irgendwie rausgekickt. Unternehmen taumelt so ein bisschen, kurz vorm Tod. Steve Jobs kommt zurück. Unternehmen geht's gut. Steve Jobs stirbt. Unternehmen so, hm, mal gucken, wie es da weitergeht, ohne so ein Genius am Werk. Und er hat aber die Nachfolge geregelt mit Tim Cook. Tim Cook nimmt also 2011 die Steuer in die Hand von Apple. Apple hat einen spezifischen Börsenwert zu dieser Zeit. Elf Jahre später, 2022, durch Bericht Apple, die Marke von drei Billionen Marktkapitalisierung. So, und das bedeutet, in Zahlen runtergebrochen. Und das sind jetzt rohe Kräfte, die walten. Die müssen contained werden. Politisch, wirtschaftlich, wie auch immer. Die Zahl lautet wie folgt. Jeden einzelnen Arbeitstag, den Tim Cook von 2011 bis 2022 bei Apple als CEO gearbeitet hat. Jeden einzelnen Arbeitstag ist der Wert von Apple im Durchschnitt um 700 Millionen Dollar gewachsen. Steve Jobs, Tim Cook steht seit zehn Jahren jeden Morgen auf und lässt sich darüber informieren, heute ist mein Unternehmen wieder 700 Millionen Dollar Mehrwert als gestern. Das sind Zahlen, die können wir uns nicht vorstellen. Das sind drohe Kräfte, für die brauchen wir Containment. Wenn dann irgendein Politiker als Person so kommt und sagt, ich mach das mal über so einen Zoll, ich droh den jetzt 25 Prozent Zoll an.
Damit ihr mal nach Hause kommt in der Produktion.
Da steht Tim Cook einfach da und sagt, eure Bedrohung, China, habe ich geschaffen. Das ist die These in diesem Buch. Das heutige China wurde von Apple geschaffen. Apple hat in China 28 Millionen Menschen ausgebildet, iPhones herzustellen. Das sind mehr Beschäftigte als ganz Kalifornien, als sechs größte Volksnationen der Welt hat. Also wir haben es hier mit Kräften zu tun, mit Größen, mit Dimensionen. Das ist einfach völlig klar. 28 Millionen Menschen sind durch die Ausbildung.
Das finde ich eigentlich die noch verrückte Zahl.
Es ist grotesk. Alles, was wir jetzt sehen in der Politik, solche Geschichten wie, da war jemand im Weißen Haus, dann gab es da ein bisschen Stress und deswegen hat der Deutsche Bundestag eine Milliarde und so weiter. Das sind diese rohen Kräfte, die jetzt so walten insgesamt. Also wir brauchen hier ernsthafte Gedanken über Containment von rohen Kräften, die einfach walten. Dieses Buch bzw. die Sachlage hinter dem Buch, aber das Buch selbst bildet es einfach wunderbar ab. Man kommt aus dem Staunen nicht raus und man wird ganz demütig und man weiß, sorry, liebe Tagesschau, aber das kann nicht so kommuniziert werden, wie ihr das gerade macht. Eine Kurzmeldung über Zollandrohung, während Apple pro Jahr, schon vor zehn Jahren, 50 Milliarden Dollar pro Jahr investiert und Amerika in dieser 20-jährigen Geschichte einmal es hinbekommt, ein Chips Act zu machen, wo es heißt, once in a lifetime, wir investieren jetzt für vier Jahre lang 12 Milliarden im Jahr.
Und sollte man nicht lieber noch mal einen Bericht machen über die Bezahlkarte für Arbeitslose? Weil Gens Spahn das fordert.
Also heute geht es ins Eingemachte mit dem Geoeconomie-Buch schon und dann mit der Praxis, was wie Gie und so, dass da alles organisiert ist. Also man kommt aus dem Staunen nicht raus.
Wir gehen damit in den Salon. Wir haben hier die Geoeconomie in Praxis. Du stellst uns das vor mit Apple. Ich bin sehr gespannt darauf. Und wir sprechen aber zunächst gemeinsam über ein Buch, das, wenn man so möchte, die theoretische Grundlage legen will für das, was dann für Apple gilt und natürlich auch andere Konzerne. Denn wir haben gerade diese Debatte. Erleben wir die große Rückkehr der Geopolitik. Das heißt also nur noch Primat des Politischen und das Wirtschaftliche wird dem untergeordnet. Mitunter scheint es so. Aber der politische Ökonom Milan Babic sagt, das ist eigentlich nicht der richtige Begriff Geopolitik und auch eigentlich nicht die richtige Betrachtungsweise. Wir müssen über Geoeconomie sprechen. Anatomie der Neuen Weltordnung heißt der Untertitel seines Buchs, das bei Surkamp erschienen ist. Und darüber werden wir ausführlich reden, auch weil dieses Buch die neoliberale Globalisierung für beendet erklärt, aber damit nicht meint, dass die Globalisierung am Ende ist. Außerdem werde ich Musik vorstellen, Jazz gibt es zu hören. Dann eine Autorin Katharina Bendigsen schreibt über Mutterschaft, über das Muttersein, über das Leben mit Kindern. Und zwar in experimenteller Kurzprose, in Geschichten. Wirklich erstaunlich. Ich bin sehr begeistert davon. Dann werde ich ein Buch, das gerade heiß diskutiert wird, vorstellen. Und zwar hat Tilman Lahme eine große neue Thomas-Mann-Biografie veröffentlicht. Und diese wirft Fragen auf, wie konnte die Germanistik und wie konnten auch die Biografen zuvor so lange blind sein oder wollten blind sein? Und man fragt sich aber auch, ist also dieser intime Blick, der hier uns gewährt wird, wirklich der Blick, der jetzt bleiben sollte, wenn wir auf Thomas Mann blicken? Denn er hat sehr viel ausfindig gemacht, wie sehr die unterdrückte Homosexualität von Thomas Mann doch sein ganzes Leben prägt und wie sehr auch dies alles immer von der Forschung dann ja übergangen oder auch verschleiert worden ist. Es ist also ganz erstaunlich, was er da zutage fördert. Es ist ein sehr gut geschriebenes Buch, das auf jeden Fall, aber auch ein Buch, über das man sicherlich diskutieren kann. Dann gibt es einen Artikel aus der Zeit, nämlich hat dort eine Journalistin Andrea Jeska mit Ukrainern gesprochen, die nicht kämpfen wollen und die sich ein Ende dieses Krieges wünschen. Und wir blicken noch mit Le Monde Diplomatie nach Rumänien. Was halten eigentlich die Rumänen von der EU?
Meinerseits gucken wir in einen Text des State Department. Die publizieren auf ZAPStack, machen also Newsletter. Und das ist trotzdem offizielle Kommunikation. Und wir gehen einmal durch, wie eine genealogische Kette vom Athen zu Rom zum mittelalterlichen Christentum, zum Common Law zur amerikanischen Gründung zu Europas Zukunft kommt, die also an JD Vans Rede da anschließt. Und wir machen uns danach auf die Suche nach Grundbegriffen, um dieses Phänomen eine Geschichte neu zu vergegenwärtigen, um sie komplett zu missbrauchen für eigene gegenwärtige Argumentationen. Mein Vorschlag wird dann der Synkretismus sein, die selektive Rekombination, aber es gibt noch andere Vorschläge. Kommt dann drauf, wie gesagt, Apple in China. Also man kommt aus dem Staunen nicht raus. Axios hat einen interessanten Text gemacht mit Dario Amodai, also der CEO von Entropic. Steve Bannon kennen wir und Mark Zuckerberg, die Zitate zum Thema, was ist, wenn es wirklich passiert und 50 Prozent der Entry-Level-Jobs einfach vom höheren Management aus Kostengründen abgeschafft werden? Wie sieht eigentlich Nachwuchs in der Hierarchie aus und so? Plus eine sehr große Studie, die von Spektrum der Wissenschaft in einen sehr kleinen Text umgemünzt wurde, in dem aber die zentralen Aussagen für uns erhalten bleiben. Warum sind Leute weltweit betrachtet, die ein bisschen im Abseits leben und von weniger als 1000 Dollar im Jahr eigentlich glücklicher als wir? Kann man sich schon mal die Frage stellen.
Kann das sein?
Glaubt man das erstens und zweitens ist es so. Das erste möchte ich sagen, es ist wahrscheinlich so. Die erhobenen Zahlen deuten es an, aber wie wir es glauben sollten, ist schwierig. Eine Anmerkung noch, ich habe Hinweis bekommen, nachdem wir so ausführlich über den, ich sage mal neuen Katholizismus gesprochen haben, weil du warst ja sehr skeptisch nachdem ich sagte, ich brauche eigentlich diese Grundprinzipien des Katholizismus, um mich auch selber daran zu orientieren, aber ich will diesen Gott nicht. Daraufhin schrieb mir Jonas, der auch schon zu ähnlichen Themen bei mir im Fernsehpodcast war, auch schon mal hier zu Gast war. Also wir haben schon ein paar Mal miteinander gesprochen. Er war selbst fünf Jahre evangelischer Pfarrer und ist dann aber da wieder sich anders orientiert und erwies mich daraufhin auf das atheistische Christentum, seine eigene Diplomarbeit, die er mir geschickt hat, hat den Titel Theologie ohne Gott. Es gibt eine Todgottesteologie, die durchaus mit einem war mal oder braucht man nicht Gottesbezug klarkommt. Er selber ist sehr skeptisch. Also Jonas sagt, die konventionellen Wurzeln wird man eigentlich nicht los, da ich aber nicht aus der gläubigen Richtung komme, sondern aus der eignischen. Finde ich das wahnsinnig interessant. Und es gibt wohl auch Kanz-Religionsschriften, die sich auch sehr, kennen wir ja natürlich, aber eben auch mit einer neuen Fundierung von Ethik und Moral eben abseits von Gottes bezügen. Also darauf läuft ja vieles hinaus, was wir so populärwissenschaftlich kennen von ihm. ganzen Imperatives, Versuche und so. Wir kommen also darauf noch mal zurück. Und beim weiteren Nachlesen bin ich auch noch mal auf einen interessanten Umstand gestoßen, denn es lohnt sich durchaus, die immer auf Latein veröffentlichen Encyclikas, wahrscheinlich Encyclikenn, mal zu übersetzen, um sich nur die Ansprache anzuhören. Denn sehr typisch ist mittlerweile, womit Papst Johannes der 23. 1963 begonnen hat in Pacham in Therese. Sie richtet sich nämlich an die ehrwürdigen Brüder, Patriarchen, Primaten, Erzbischöfe, Bischöfe und sonstige Ortsordinarien, die in Frieden und Gemeinschaft mit dem apostolischen Stuhl leben, an den Klerus und die Gläubigen, die ganze Welt sowie an alle Menschen guten Willens. Also wir sind ganz explizit inkludiert in dieser Ansprache, was auch so weit geht, dass Laudato Si von 2015 noch mal allgemeiner auf die Formel hinausläuft in der Ansprache, an jeden Menschen, der auf diesem Planeten wohnt. Also dieser Katholizismus und ich will noch mal sagen, weil Jonas jetzt auch mehr über die evangelische Kirche kommt, mir ist schon wichtig, dass es da eine Hierarchie gibt, mir ist wichtig, dass es einen Papst gibt, dass es eine Adresse in Rom gibt und so weiter. Also das ist mir wichtig, aber der Gottesbezug ist mir nicht so wichtig. Und das finde ich wahnsinnig interessant, dass der Vatikan selbst in seinen zentralen Schriften sich sowieso schon immer an mich richtet, auch. Und das kann ich ja mal vergelten.
Denn du bist ja nicht verloren, du kannst ja auch noch missioniert werden, von daher ist das schon ganz sinnvoll und es ist eine ganz interessante Gegenposition, die du da einnimmst, denn wenn man jetzt schaut, was die Kirchenkritiken in den vergangenen Jahren, Jahrzehnten besonders in Deutschland ausmachte, dann war das ja eine Kritik der Kleriker an diesem ganzen System, bis hin auch zum Papst, also auch die Fragestellung einer solchen Hierarchie. Und man hat da so eine Kirche von unten gedacht, so heißt er dann auch in der Organisation. Und das war immer zu sagen, Gott und wir wollen eigentlich unmittelbarer auch mit Gott in Bezug sein und wollen nicht diese Organisation, weil die natürlich auch patriarchal geprägt ist und all das oder geprägt dominiert ist, muss man sagen, haben. Und du sagst jetzt nein, ich will eigentlich die Organisation, aber bitte ohne den lieben Gott. Mir reicht der Papst an der Spitze, ein vernünftiger Mann.
Genau. Und mit Organisation meine ich ja auch dieses Containment durch die Organisation. Weil ich als Soziologe einfach sage, es geht nur durch Organisation. Also einfach jeder macht Freischaffen so einen Gottesbezug und erhält dann so eine Predigt, dann kommen 20 Leute vorbei, weil sie Lust drauf haben. Also so, ich will es jetzt nicht zu vulgär, aber so dieser evangelische Charakter, dass auch in Amerika einfach jeder selber seine Kirche erfindet und am Ende ist das so eine Musical-Show oder so, die da abläuft. Das will ich ja nicht, sondern ich will schon dieses ernst gemeinte Containment über Organisationen nur, und das ist ja ganz früh Thomas von Aquin, der ja auch schon mit dieser Idee, Thomas Theorem und so, wie wäre es, ich weiß gar nicht, ob das Thomas Theorem von Thomas von Aquin, ich habe es jetzt so im Kopf zusammen, aber ihr kennt vielleicht das Thomas Theorem, wenn etwas eine Wirkung zeigt, wird es ja wohl eine Ursache haben. Wenn sich also Leute versammeln und die sagen alle, wir sind hier wegen Gott, dann sagt der Theologe, ja genau, und dann sagt aber der Soziologe, nein, nein, der Regentanz ist nicht dafür da, damit der Regen kommt, sondern damit die Leute was zu tun haben, während sie auf Regen warten und alle so im gleichen Rhythmus. Und da ist natürlich der soziologische Einschlag wichtig.
Ja, man muss das vielleicht für die Leute, die sich nicht so gut kennen, erklären. Du hast ja, wenn darf ich das erzählen, wir waren einmal auf der Gamescom in Köln und sind danach noch was trinken gegangen. Roman war auch dabei und dort war ein Straßenfest. Und ich habe mich natürlich gleich aufgeregt, dass jetzt schon wieder irgendwo so laute Musik ist. Und du hast dich darüber gefreut, nicht weil du jetzt auf der Straßenfest wolltest, sondern du freutest dich darüber, dass die Leute sich freuen.
Genau.
Und so ist auch deine Betrachtung natürlich mit dem Katholizismus. Du freust dich, dass das so gut funktioniert. Die Show ist perfekt. Die Leute freuen sich, in Rom zu sein. Der Papst ist glücklich, alle sind froh. Und das ist deine Haltung. Also bei dir ist es auch gar nicht so, du willst jetzt unbedingt dich mit da reinwerfen. Ja, also du sagst jetzt nicht, ich möchte irgendwie ein epiphanisches Erlebnis haben, sondern dir reicht es zu sehen, dass Menschen sich organisiert haben und miteinander eine gute Zeit haben.
Ja, es ist eine ganz kleine technische Errungenschaft, aber die für mich ganz bedeutend war dieses Jahr. Denn wir hatten ein Papst, der jetzt dem Volk, dem Land, dem Erdkreis, den Menschen gezeigt wurde. Und das erste Mal konnten Drohnen über den Petersplatz fliegen. Sie kamen also von hinten, haben auf den Zinnen noch die Statuen gezeigt und dann war klar, da unten steht die Masse. Also man hat einen ganz neuen ästhetischen Einschlag auf das Ding. Man sieht zuerst das Volk und dann fliegt die Drohne rum und zeigt den Balkon und so. Oder eben man kommt von der anderen Seite und ist auf Augenhöhe des Papstes, der aber auf dem Balkon steht. Also man steht nicht unten und guckt hoch oder so, sondern die Drohne fängt ihn so auf Augenhöhe einfach ein. Man sieht die ganze Fassade aber asymmetrisch richtig und nicht aus so einer Perspektive. Und das sind alles solche kleinen ästhetischen Einschläge, von denen ich mich auch zurücklernen an so Texte, die ich dann mal über die englische Kirche geschrieben habe bei dieser Fragestellung. Die englische Kirche hat 100, 200, 300 Jahre, nachdem sie ihre Macht verlor, plötzlich so viel Aufmerksamkeit wie nichts. Also Lady Di ist tot und so. Das hat ja einen Fokus auf die Kirche, auf die englische Krone geworfen. Das war selbst der englische Krone nicht mehr geheuer. Wie viel Aufmerksamkeit sie plötzlich haben, wie wirkmächtig kleinste Kommunikation sind und so. Was ja aus unserer Medienbetrachtung, und wir haben über George Clooney als Präsidenten gesprochen, bedeutet, so mächtig war die englische Krone noch nie, wie in diesen Momenten. Das sind alles solche Sachen, die containen. Ich bleibe jetzt heute für euch mal beim Containment. Die containen rauwaltende Kräfte in dieser Gesellschaft, die strukturieren, die geben Leute Orientierung. Da oben ist der Balkon, da findet es statt und so. Aber eigentlich, da winkt halt mal kurz jemand, ja. Aber man ist ja trotzdem da und man erinnert sich daran, wie man da war. Und das Gerede heute noch über die Fußball-WM 2006 in Deutschland und so zeigt ja, um was es da geht.
Wir werden jetzt gleich nicht katholisch werden, sondern wir sprechen über die handfesten Dinge, die Geoökonomie. Wir sprechen über Apple, aber auch über Thomas Mann. Wir feiern ja seinen 150. Geburtstag in diesem Monat. Da ist es, glaube ich, interessant, noch mal einen neuen Blick auf Thomas Mann einzunehmen. Um all das wird es gehen im Salon. Wir freuen uns, wenn ihr den Salon abonniert und auf diese Weise auch den Podcast unterstützt. Also auch alles, was vor der Paywall stattfindet, unterstützt ihr natürlich dadurch, dass ihr den Salon abonniert. Ihr könnt übrigens den Salon auch verschenken. Bei Steady gibt es Pakete, die man anwählen kann. So kann man jemanden, den man mag oder bei dem man glaubt, der müsste mal aufgeklärt werden über einige Dinge, kann man also den Podcast dann für ein Jahr verschenken. Auch das ist kein Problem. Bei Steady ist es ganz einfach. Man geht auf die neu20er.de Seite, klickt dort auf den Salon-Button und dann kann man sich bei Steady ein Paket auswählen, hat dann Zugang auch zu allen Salons zuvor und hat auch Zugang zu den Live-Salons. Denn in diesem Monat im Juni findet auch wieder ein Live-Salon in Frankfurt statt, der schon ausverkauft ist. Aber am Tag danach gibt es dann das, was wir auf der Bühne getrieben haben, dann auch zu hören. Dann gibt es noch für die Leute, die schon bei Patreon sind, die Möglichkeit, über Patreon abzuschließen. Und du erklärst noch, wie das über Apple geht, wenn man Apple-Kunde ist.
Das ist am einfachsten, wenn man eh schon über Apple-Podcasts hört, was hier irgendwie, also mehr als die Hälfte der Leute hören uns über iPhones. Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen elitär. Ach, das ist ein sehr elitärer Podcast.
Das hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Ja, die iPhones sind ja auch sehr gute Geräte. Wir werden ja gleich aufklären. Da taucht ja der Salon einfach im regulären also Apple Podcasts App-Feed auf.
Ja.
Nun klickt man einfach. Aber ganz wichtig, man kann auch seinen Steady RSS Feed, der billiger und vollständiger und so weiter ist, in der Podcasts App abonnieren von Apple.
Ja, man muss nicht dafür sorgen, dass Tim Cook noch mehr als 700 Millionen am Tag verdient. Das reicht ja auch dann vielleicht. Aber wir können sagen, mit deinem Thema Apple sprechen wir jetzt wirklich 50 Prozent des Publikums dann direkt an. Weil andere ein iPhone Besitzer sind. Heute ist heute ist Apple Podcasts und ich kann jetzt ja auch mitreden. Ich habe ja eins und habe schon ein bisschen damit rumprobiert, wie gesagt, ohne Social Media oder so. Aber ich bin sehr gespannt, was du jetzt über vor allem ja die Hardware uns erzählen wirst. Also dann sehen wir uns gleich im Salon. Bis gleich.